my name is Gavin Wilson I'm the CEO of
IFC as a management company i'm a member
of the Council on private capital and
the new model that we've been discussing
is whether or not we can persuade the
private capital industry in general and
specifically private equity fund
managers to be more transparent about
their way of investing and more
importantly their performance and you
may think that private equity firms talk
about that performs the whole time and
the last thing we want is for them to
spend more time talking about it but the
fact of the matter is there's a lot of
murkiness about how returns are
calculated and we feel that if there are
more transparency about this and more
common standards in terms of how returns
or measure then actually the private
equity industry would be doing itself a
favor because it would illustrate how
well it's not our sorting hypothesis is
that private equity does achieve
superior returns but frankly people see
such two scored and data and that it's
very difficult for pension funds
endowments and other long-term investors
to really feel comfortable about what it
is they're getting into so our new model
is to find some mechanism some
institution maybe it's just a
behavioural norm that needs changing
which can collect data and maybe on an
anonymous basis distribute that or make
it available to people who want to
understand exactly what returns be made
by private capital providers as opposed
to other sorts of investors in public
equity for instance where the returns
are much more transparent